salut à tous vous cela oui ce samedi
alors c'est sûr vous vous demandez
pourquoi je suis en sueur et quelque peu
souffler c'est simplement que j'ai dû
courir aller chercher ma clé à bout de
ma ville et croyez moi c'est plutôt
épuisant ghoul ta vie ta coup lorsque
vous vous souvenez de ce jeu un petit
peu walter qu'on avait testé tous
ensemble et qui ma foi était fort
amusant 1 c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
waouh ont été ensuite retourné dessus
mais cette fois pour un contre un avec
une demoiselle
alors cette fois on est de retour sur le
jeu mais je vous promets deux fois plus
de fun que lorsque ces deux vidéos parce
que j'ai trouvé des modes à savoir la
nouvelle map et croyez moi c'est trois
fois que lui donnant alors vous savez
quoi
rené m'a tout de suite
regardez là ce chat est actuellement en
train de se laisser mourir religion nous
voici donc sur le jeu alors on a testé
ça c'est la première map d'en avoir huit
ou neuf je sais pas ou même beaucoup
plus
on va tester je sais pas encore à quoi
m'attendre j'ai pas que ça va ressembler
apparemment on est en haut d'une tour en
asphalte ogier tour bon je vous rappelle
que bien évidemment sumotori est un vrai
jeu de gogol vous allez trêve vous allez
très vite comprendre pourquoi alors
attendons pas à ce problème je pense que
je vais te rejoins de mec non mais
pourquoi ils s'allongent comme ça
devient bas
vas-y vas-y oh là là là là mais il est
super on peut passer seul non merde je
vais me lancer comme on a fait la
dernière fois vous savez j'avais réussi
à sauter on va y aller comme ça on va le
pousser tiens tiens ta fac alors allé à
toi l'autre là il va me rejoindre ce
qu'on y va
bonjour moi je suis en bas sans tarder
et rossia hommes [ __ ] c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi c'est pas mal on teste la
deuxième la deuxième alors la map
s'appelle toy lot mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire
je suis même pas à côté de lui olala
falloir qu'on se concentre non à long
nez dans des chiottes géante
on est d'enrichir géantes mais c'est
quoi ça regardez bien c'est censé
montrer l'eau même si l'euro est plutôt
bizarre
patard viens viens là tio tio coup de
balayette et a pris cher à attendait
ouverts tournés voir et en bas y'a quoi
j'aimerais bien voir la vue d'en bas en
fait à l'interné on va circuler voilà
comme ça qu'est ce qu'il fait y dansera
robot basque c'est bien d'étoilés
géantes aaa est la suivante à cette ma
place s'appelle soccer on va pouvoir
jouer au foot les gens voilà comment
comment mais un tien matin tiens au fait
vous marquez voilà tant ils sont drôles
comment tu veux des place et un ballon
avec des contrôles aussi pourri on va
essayer de tout est dedans à toi dégage
non ben ali ouais mais bien un coup de
main aux mêmes on va je lâche fait oh oh
oh oh c'est un peu un jeu sexuel quand
même ce truc qu'on va pas se mentir
c'est assez assez fou vient là j'ai pas
fait mais avec toi non karakama de
l'autre côté c'est n'importe quoi non
mais sans dec
non mais oh je te prends sur la mappe
prochaine lek
alors la prochaine ses slides alors où
ça a l'air intéressant tout ça
allez hop c'est parti ça a l'air
intéressant je pense qu'on le pousse
dans la pente bien bien bien on pousse
dans la porte
tu savais pantillon les joueurs de
l'alaric compris aux non non non comment
on peut le rejoindre parce que moi par
faire une crise d'épilepsie en eau du
truc je ne sais pas trop à quoi je sers
elle relève toi on va y aller à temps il
se relève à l'ego qu'au fond ce qui
fonce la tête la première
on dirait deux gros bout de jambon c'est
absolument dégueulasse
voilà les caméras king je vois pas où je
vais au jeu mais j'étais en arrière
hu ah merde elle continue bien là coup
de tête rousse balayette potes et voilà
c'est qu'il est patron aux [ __ ] on
dirait j'ai franchement suicidaire
j'allais vraiment deux gros morceaux de
jambon jeter rejoint regarder le cul en
l'air il se rassoit
mais moi je galère au nom à chaque fois
j'ai le réflexe de faire espace pour
sauter bon je prends chaque match et
vente savez quoi
alors cette pas cette nappe là pardon
c'est paul paul comme le pôle voilà
fâchent comme le pôle simplement
hugh quennec touche technique et toi
t'es qui toi dans je me fais reiki
calabre ou semi je suis sûr en l'air et
la criée watch
bon allez t on peut péter le décor
attendait faudrait qu'on arrive à péter
le décor je reviens cas c'est ce truc au
milieu là bas on y va cash
on est déterminés chaque enfant rien
c'est un truc de malade ce jeu alors
cette ma place et je sais même plus dont
j'étais tellement pressé de la tester où
on va pouvoir jouer en équilibre
apparemment a tant pis moi est ce moral
et sur mes trucs en équilibre qua non au
poche revoit c'est quoi le but de ce jeu
bordel de merde on y retourne là y'a
moyen de faire un truc non non non j'ai
plongé d'éveil désarticulé qu'ils
prennent des poutres en bois sur rail
chargé de gens bizarres suspense
incroyable suspense incroyable
graille tiens ton nom il met des mains
dans les dégâts au rsa s'est cassé
vienne fait surprenant moi je vais
tomber dans le trou je t'aimais mon père
adieu alors la map s'appelle house donc
on est dans une maison je pense qu'on va
juste failli dans une maison t'es qui
toi
tu as cassé ma maison je me vois sur le
champ vient de battre bien bat avec tes
grosses fesses bien grail tiens j'ai pas
gagné non son sérieux personne a gagné
mais c'est pas possible il est tombé
pourtant on y retourne direct non mais
non mais non mais non mais non mais non
deux jours tient stif méfaits stupéfait
ce pour nextmap appelé iphone alors je
suppose qu'on va tomber de très haut
c'est parti alors là l'allégeance et là
c'est là c'est pour toi c'est pour toi
et regarde cette vidéo
bah je vais me roesch limite fautes
tombent dans les abysses tombe
voilà sort de la map dégage dégage je
les fais une de ses feintes on est passé
sur l'autre croit bim bam boum ac et
ignorent genou je suis resté
attendez je vais me remets way s'est pas
cassé j'ai eu un bac gars très étonnant
un bug pour un jeu du genre dit donc
c'est un gros troll
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'est ce qu'ils font
ils font des fessiers c'est pas moins de
faire des pétioles et beck
cette fois la mab bridge tu veux dire
pont en anglais ben c'est captain
obvious alors attendez s'il tombe là
haut
bon perso il a rien compris de
compresseurs il a compris franchement là
incroyable
pour finir vécu la dernière map qui
ressemble à rien vous dire qu'on va
marcher sur des braises
tiens qu'est ce t'as tout on pousse dans
le décor ou plus dans les cordes
attendait fait qu'on se tourne un peu
bon allez vrai faux quitte ce jeu
complètement what the fuck si vous
voulez télécharger les maps et dans la
description je voudrais un petit peu
aussi comment faire
et puis voilà on se retrouve bientôt
dans une nouvelle vidéo chat demandé sa
main tôt et nous on se quitte sur le
relevage du magnifique comme blue on
n'est pas les [ __ ] l'homme pervers
écoute élevé de la rivière et est tombé
sur nous c'est un métier ce que vous
voulez vivre sans dec